Коронавірус поширюється не лише в Італії,
а й інших європейських країнах, зокрема, і в Німеччині.
Кількість заражених зростає.
Як контролюють захворювання у ФРН?
Чи можлива ізоляція цілого населеного пункту?
Ось як боротьба з вірусом відбувається у Німеччині:
За перших ознак захворювання на коронавірус
німців закликають звернутися до "сімейного лікаря" -
і вже він вирішуватиме, чи необхідні аналізи.
Наразі діагностика триває добу.
Людину з ознаками хвороби закликають одразу обмежити контакти із зовнішнім світом:
не виходити на роботу і не відвідувати місця скупчення людей.
Якщо зараження коронавірусом підтвердиться,
лікар повідомить про це місцевий відділ охорони здоров'я.
Той поінформує земельне міністерство та Інститут Роберта Коха -
наукову установу, що займається дослідженням вірусу
та розробляє медичні рекомендації.
Саме цей інститут в разі пандемії мусить повідомити
про ситуацію компетентні органи ЄС та
Світову організацію охорони здоров'я.
Пацієнта, в якого підтверджено коронавірус, доправляють до лікарняного закладу,
який визначить місцева влада.
Це може бути спеціальний ізолятор у клініці
або ж відділення інтенсивної терапії звичайної лікарні.
Окрім ізоляції хворого, у Німеччині передбачене обслідування
та карантин імовірно інфікованих.
Відповідальність за обстеження усіх, хто міг заразитися коронавірусом,
покладається на місцеві (приміром, міські або районні) органи охорони здоров'я.
Вони мусять скласти список усіх, із ким контактував хворий,
опитати їх та відправити здавати необхідні аналізи.
У разі потреби (тобто якщо є підозра на інфікування),
цих людей можуть відправити на двотижневий карантин.
Це може бути домашня ізоляція або військова казарма,
як це було з евакуйованими з Уханю німцями -
14 днів вони провели на базі Бундесверу в Ґермерсгаймі.
Доправляють до Німеччини евакуйованих літаками Люфтваффе.
А ще в разі кризової ситуації - пандемії або підвищеної небезпеки -
військові можуть допомогти облаштувати мобільні шпиталі,
щоб забезпечити якнайшвидшу ізоляцію хворих.
Теоретично у Німеччині можливо ізолювати від зовнішнього світу
цілі населені пункти - як і в Італії -
оголосити містечко "червоною зоною",
огородити воєнізованими патрулями і контролювати в’їзд-виїзд.
Однак, пояснюють експерти, це можливо, тільки коли подібне рішення
спільно ухвалять представники місцевого органу охорони здоров"я,
місцевої громади і поліції.
Спустити таке рішення "згори" просто так - німецьке законодавство не дозволяє.
Крім того, німці скептичні щодо адміністративних "кордонів" для вірусу.
Німецьке МОЗ тим часом через соцмережі і ЗМІ запустило інформкампанію -
що необхідно знати про коронавірус і як від нього захиститися.
Попри на перший погляд злагоджену схему та активне інформування громадськості,
у Німеччині чимало невдоволених тим, як вибудовано систему.
Передусім, довгий час було не зрозуміло, хто мав оплачувати тести на коронавірус -
через це лікарі зволікали з відправленням пацієнтів на аналізи,
а експерти не виключали, що кількість заражених у Німеччині
може бути більшою, ніж це відображено в офіційній статистиці.
Міністерства транспорту й охорони здоров'я, нарікають у Німеччині,
не могли визначитись, хто ж ухвалює рішення,
якщо підозру на вірус виявили, скажімо,
в потязі або автобусі.
А крім того, далеко не всім німцям видається ефективною схема,
коли рішення про заходи безпеки
ухвалюються виключно на регіональному рівні -
адже люди побоюються,
що цього може виявитися недостатньо.